interview technicolor ans ne bouge pas
pendant le single bon on ne bouge pas on
arrête tout le monde bouge supporter
nawak la normale je crois pas ça ouais
là que des révolutionnaires beigbeder
julie baffie
heureusement que nos amis tchèques sont
respectueux du règlement
alors là c'est une révolution de velours
et oui exactement
serge july ce qui vous rend vert de rage
moi qui ne suis pas du tout pour
l'interdiction de quoi que ce soit en
particulier pas de loft story mais enfin
oui c'est moi un peu vers de ré alors
qu'on vous expliquez que votre
chroniqueur télévision david dufresne il
a expliqué comme daniel schneidermann
dans le monde d'ailleurs au départ est
trouvé ça formidable il ya une semaine
en prison commencé à mettre un peu aimée
parce que un journal
qui fait par des journalistes oui c'est
pluriel oui donc vous ça vous énerve
plus que david dufresne
moi oui voilà mais si c'est le côté vous
savez dans cette affaire-là
ça me rappelle une pièce que vous devez
connaître et une très belle pièce de
théâtre qui s'appelle la dispute de
marivaux une passe au 18e et ya deux
aristocrates qui s'interroge sur l'amour
c'est comment ça se passe l'infidélité
entre les gens commencent à nay et il
dit si il décide de dire bon on va voir
on va faire un exercice on va prendre
quatre jeunes gens deux filles deux
garçons ça se passe au xviiie siècle
deux jeunes filles deux jeunes garçons
qui n'ont eu aucune histoire on va les
faire élevé par des serviteurs qui n'ont
absolument aucun contact
et puis quand ils seront grands
adolescents on verra ce qui se passera
ce qui se passe il se passe une tragédie
et ça fait penser à ça la différence
c'est que c'est marivaux qui écrit alors
que la c5 marivaux qui écrit willaya pas
le scénario et dialogues dialogue
lorraine est inquiet créer une structure
mais c'est terrible cette histoire parce
que quand libération fait sa une avec
love story on y voit là 15% de plus donc
pas ce que c'est d'un point de vue
sociologique c'est une des questions les
plus patients qui soit moi je je
remercie m6 d'avoir fait cette émission
pourquoi alors que je suis vert de rage
pourquoi mais parce que c'est le plus
grand débat qu'ont eu sur la télévision
d'un être dont j'étais très bien c'est
la der la terre de mer et ghazi sur aziz
oui finalement c'est vers ça qu'il veut
être connu et en menant est pourquoi
pour être connu oui mais non sera publié
avec lui pour être comme on est dans une
émission de télévision c'est en gros
c'est une vision du paradis terrestre
ce loft à la porte de la chapelle dans
une vision du paradis terrestre
puisqu'on mais pas loin d'ici le salon
pour elle elle m'a dit sion pourrait y
aller d'ailleurs et d'à côté allez on y
va tout
dans ce paradis terrestre la longue file
des principales c'est un grande son âme
pour passer à la télévision n'est pas
certain de quoi pour passer à la télé on
est dans une émission de télévision donc
il faut marcher et donc ça ça nous
touche tous
en fait il faut vous regardez love story
nadeau midem un départ complètement
excuses à jamais par la star garde
château story bien qu est ce qui vous
rend rouge de honte
c'est de m'être trompé on fait des
erreurs
y compris dans les papiers fins ma part
la dernière fois va pas recommencer
oui mais ça mérite qu'on a fait le
notaire la dernière passe voilà ça c'est
bruay en artois le tertre on arrête moi
en tout cas c'est pas mal mais voilà
c'est le problème des épisodes
voilà ce qu'ils ont raté leurs
précédents tant pis pour eux qu'est ce
qu'ils vont en bleu de peur je peux
souffler voyez dix mois que la fonte de
la calotte polaire le réchauffement oui
voilà faire merci frédéric faisant
président ça monte d'un mètre
ouais ça va quand même été bien fait là
est terrible nous savourons bleus de
peur oui bafa c'est pas pour demain
mieux mais c'est comme j'ai une petite
fille formidable c'est malin génial
quatre mois et demi
donc qu'est ce qu'ils vont en rose de
bonheur cette petite fille sa mère
qu'est ce qui vous fait rire jaune
blake et mortimer voilà serge july
entretien avec alain juppé
c
entre qu'à ce jeu